kevin incredible story there todd thank
you so much meantime st thomas
university in florida is pledging to
bring students back on campus next week
and that's actually
in stark relief compared to some
colleges across the nation beginning the
semester remotely and that's happening
despite accepting millions and millions
of dollars that is in government coveted
funds and here to react is the president
of st thomas university david armstrong
senior at st thomas university abigail
delva senior at the university of uh
chicago audrey unver firth who was
actually remote learning for the first
couple weeks of the semester and campus
reform correspondent and vanity student
jordan estwick uh
professor armstrong president armstrong
let me begin with you
i have to say as someone who lived in
south florida i'm familiar with your
university it is very well regarded and
i'm sure a lot of the students and to
say nothing of the faculty appreciate
the fact that you're making sure that
the optimal education is happening by
having students back on campus
absolutely kevin thanks for having us on
and from the beginning of the pandemic
we made a decision at st thomas
university to make decisions for our
students
we were not going to make decisions
based on the panic political or the
timid we were going to make decisions on
what was best to give our students a
full collegiate experience while keeping
our most vulnerable safe
and with the support of the federal
government we've been able to purchase
things and uh chemical biocides salt
water biocides to help clean the campus
and move forward to make sure that we
give a full completed experience
athletically residence life student
activities and it's one of the reasons
why we've set three straight years of
record enrollment and our largest and
strongest class in the history of the
law school this year i was going to say
and a stellar law school to boot let me
uh bring you into the conversation
abigail listen i think it's uh anyone's
uh joy to get out there and see the palm
trees but you know sometimes it does
actually help i imagine having the
interactivity not just with professors
but also with your fellow students tell
me what that's like for you
um i've had a great experience you had
saint thomas i know that we're taking
all the necessary precautions and
following all the necessary protocols to
ensure a safe and great semester
meanwhile audrey uh
you're actually unfortunately doing
remote learning for the first couple
weeks
up in chicago listen i get it sometimes
you this sort of thing happens uh but
i'm sure you'd like to get back out
there and see your fellow students how
are you handling uh that uh remote
learning circumstance
absolutely well i wish the university of
chicago were similarly following the
science it's honestly a little bit
embarrassing that we're going back into
more coveted theater more zoom
university which is a lousy substitute
for in-person real education there's
just no excuse for it anymore
and no comparison is what i'm hearing
from a lot of college students they
simply say listen it's just not the same
uh jordan i think you would probably
agree with that what's your take
yeah absolutely i mean vanderbilt we've
effectively been uh locked down uh
in the beginning of school i can't leave
my dorm room uh to go to the library to
eat at the dining hall if i go to my
synagogue and my friends go to mass we
could be suspended we could be expelled
we'd have to go through a disciplinary
process i actually transferred a
vanderbilt from a school in california
thinking that it being in the south
they'd be a little more salient about
these issues it turns out that you have
the same woke administrators there as
you do in chicago i assume and they're
just as irrational about this glorified
cold
well i can tell you're a smart student
if you got into vandy before we go i
want to share for the folks at home the
colleges that received some of this
government money we're talking about
massive amounts of money to ensure the
educational experience to get students
back on campus yale duke temple u-dub up
in seattle vandy you just heard
mentioned there and even down at the u
41 million dollars david armstrong
abigail delva audrey unver firth and
jordan estwick we really appreciate you
guys getting up early for us and
spending time as we continue to unpack
what could be a very interesting
semester for you all thank you again